COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some content streamers
figure out their optimal window
sizes.
Will we fetch the
right solution?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For the internet video
streaming company Mega Streams,
the most critical aspect
of their operation
is the sweet spot between
user connection speed,
cloud hosting performance,
and the window size you
use to buffer and request data.
Their current architecture is
serving video data directly
from Google Cloud
Storage buckets
to users on mobile
and desktop devices.
Over the past
month, they've been
trying to figure out the right
way to duplicate their content
and optimize their window sizes
so they can ensure consistent
buffering to their clients
across the US and EU,
which we can help them figure
out by profiling how the read
performance adjusts at various
window sizes of download.
To figure this out, I
wrote a very simple script
which creates a regional
bucket, creates a bunch of files
at a bunch of
different file sizes,
and uploads to that
bucket, and then
downloads each one of those
files 100 times via HTTP
Fetch--
with caching disabled.
That's important to know.
This graph shows the 50th
percentile for those times.
And that, for fetches
under one megabyte,
we can see very consistent
read performance.
But one graph never
tells the complete story.
So, we can switch our
test just slightly
to get a better view of things.
Now, let's take
an 8-megabyte file
and fetch it through
different-sized chunks.
This graph helps us see
our read performance
from another perspective.
As the chunk size decreases,
the overhead per transaction
increases, thus
making things slower.
Combined, these two graphs
illustrate something important.
Now, much like write
throughput, GCS
is extremely strong in terms of
single-stream throughput, which
means that for both
uploads and downloads,
GCS is at its best
performance when
you're favoring larger
requests-- about one
megabyte in size.
Otherwise, the
per-transaction overhead
of the requests themselves
will start to slow things down.
For Mega Streams, this was
a massively helpful piece
of data.
They now had the
ability to determine
what level of
regional redundancy
they needed for serving
their video content in order
to optimize the 1-megabyte GCS
target to improve buffering
speeds.
Data saves the day.
[LAUGHS]
To learn more about how Mega
Streams improved their upload
performance, check out
the related article
linked in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our "Cloud
Performance Atlas"
content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]